es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn ihr
nach diesem video irgendwelche komischen
vorstellungen und eurem kopf hat
die habe ich auch mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video habe vor einiger zeit ein
video hochgeladen in dem ich auf
komische videos von kues wie die world
reagiert habe und jetzt befinden wir uns
wieder auf dieser website das heißt sie
sind ja erst mal falls sie nicht was das
überhaupt ist auf der website to the
world werden komische 3d animation von
usern hochgeladen die alles sehr komisch
sind
das ist glaube ich die beste
beschreibung meine ganze sache geben
kann
das hier ist das erste video mit dem
namen button man das heißt wir klicken
einfach mal drauf sehen da ist eine
person
er liegt und das angeht in seinem tor
und da kommt ein schmetterling raus
leute wer kennt es nicht und der
schmetterling krieg wieder drauf
[Musik]
das war's
solche videos werden auf dieser website
hochgeladen das nächste video heißt live
wave das heißt hier klicken einfach mal
auf play wir sehen eine person die in
einem krankenbett liegt dort jetzt wird
das baby rausgezogen und es schaut
natürlich direkt in die kamera es sieht
zum glück überhaupt nicht verstören aus
das baby lernt laufen läuft auf die
mutter zu jetzt steht das baby einfach
in ihrem kleinen bettchen und trainiert
mit hanteln ich meine wenn es nicht ich
habe natürlich auch mit fünf jahren
angefangen jetzt ist es in der schule
trainiert natürlich weiter natürlich
leute auch er findet eine frau sie
zwinkert ihr zu die beiden ich habe
darauf habe ich sogar schon mal reagiert
die beiden laufen auf jeden fall über
einen blumenfeld fangen nun an zu
heiraten mit einem priester im
hintergrund alles wunderbar nun sind sie
alt und sitzen nackt auf der veranda und
schaukeln rum die eine spielt der andere
es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn ihr
nach diesem video irgendwelche komischen
vorstellungen und eurem kopf hat
hab ich auch das nächste video heißt
nail'd hat das heißt jemand schneidet
seine fingernägel
wir kriegen einfach mal darauf dass auf
jeden fall eine sehr sehr hoch
ist das video hier 18 laut dieser video
beschreibung beziehungsweise laut
youtube auf diesem video ist dieses
video nicht ab 18 freigegeben ich wette
mein video hier ist trotzdem aber 18
leute ihr konntet die szene zwar gerade
nicht sehen ich verlinke ich aber
trotzdem weil die website unten da könnt
ihr euch das video noch mal angucken ich
habe vorhin alles zensiert das heißt
wenn dieses video ab 18 ist dann
verklage ich die person die das ab 18
freigegeben hat weil ich sehe diese
person ist auf wen er ich weiß nicht mal
ob das video wirklich ab 18 freigegeben
wird aber ich tu's und so als 14 der
fall sein
the dreaming ist der titel dieses videos
beziehung werte dieser episode es geht
31 ein kleiner junge hüpft auf einem
fetten bauch herum der dicke mann fällt
runter sein
jetzt haben wir hier eine rote person
die sich aufteilt in mehrere rote
personen erfolg
passiert da er ist im kopf er kurz
jemanden er fährt runter da kommt ihnen
was draußen vogel der vogel fliegt
zwischen mehreren metall ähnlichen
gegenstand her wir haben hier jetzt eine
person die so dick ist und er liegt
wieder im bett und anscheinend war
tatsächlich alles nur ein traum das
heißt er wacht jetzt auf man sieht ihn
wieder nackt im bett liegen und
hesserode person
war oben zum fix sind die aliens alter
schwede wie kommen wir zu den aliens und
es ist vorbei
was ist das für ein scheiß cruel world
präsenz das bildfeld aus wir sehen eine
tänzerin bislang auf das sky lag ist der
titel da sehen wir nämlich immer noch
eine tänzerin die dort hinten im wasser
ihre übungen vollzieht ich bin diesmal
wirklich gespannt ob dieses video an
tieferen sinn haben wird weil ich meine
da ist mit ballett tänzerinnen das sieht
echt gut animiert aus die steht mitten
im wasser beschwört nun irgendwas herauf
und das ist ihr gesicht in das wir jetzt
gerade reingeflogen sind dort ist eine
anderes und das ist sogar echt gut
modelliert alltag ein paar sekunden
später mittlerweile haben wir hier vier
personen leute ich weiß nicht ob das
ganze noch irgendwie zu retten ist wir
schauen uns ein zahnfleisch angucken wie
er uns nicht angucken irgendwie
entwickeln die sich dort alle tiere da
laufen jetzt drei leute auf diese
balletttänzerin von beginn an
sie machen einen kreis beschwören
vielleicht jetzt irgendwas ich bin echt
gespannt also hier sind leute die stehen
alle im kreis ich weiß nicht was genau
die machen jetzt haben wir hier in typen
der nerd
schaut mal läuten vogel der dort einsam
auf einer klippe steger und jetzt kommt
er an
in ordnung
fast zum volk habe ich mir gerade
angeguckt dieses video hier heißt
creation dh wir haben erstmal in der
mitte einen roten ball der dort ein
bisschen rum später haben wir eine
familie die in ihrem tollen haus
irgendwie auf dem boden liegt
irgendwelche komischen substanzen werden
dort zusammengefasst ich weiß nicht
genau was das ist gegen eine kugel wird
durch ein system geschleudert wo sich
sogar eine person darin befindet das
ganze kraft nun in einem schwein dort
oben haben wir immer noch eine person
die jetzt mittlerweile sich immer noch
einer kugel befindet die schickt sich
selbst ins weltall und das war's
mache ich mit meinem leben dieses video
heißt der killer also wir haben einen
camper der vor seinem auto sitzt und
jetzt ist er vor seinem grill mit seinem
papagei als nächstes ist er hier mit
seinen freunden vor einem schulbus sie
freuen sich dass sie gefilmt werden
hier haben wir ein wiesel auf einem berg
wo natürlich wieder der chiller sitzt
jetzt ist er auf seinem stuhl unter sind
sehr sehr viele andere schüler die auch
mit ihm schütteln er hebt die hände hoch
zeigt seine krone wir sehen nun ihn mit
seinen ganzen leuten alle feiern sich
und das war's
wenn es euch gefällt
dann lasst doch einfach mal ein paar
leute da dieses video hier heißt worlds
das heißt es könnte wirklich sein dass
wir jetzt so ein bisschen was über die
welt lernen wir sehen mich hier einen
typen der tanz in einer box in einem
anderen menschen jetzt schon wieder am
arsch
was soll mir das sagen alter dieses
video heißt basketball meine damen und
herren wir sehen mehrere cheerleader die
ich hier cheerleadern wir sehen mehrere
leute die jetzt auf basketball spielen
sie lauf auf einen korb zu verwandeln
sich alle zusammen zu einem großen
basketball spieler und treffen den korb
und das war's
dieses komplette video besteht aus der
scheiße akku und ich danach sage das was
wir schauen uns nun ein kurs wie die uhr
video an in dem es um eine flasche geht
in der flasche befindet sich ein kopf
der dort hin und her getragen wird die
person trägt die flasche rüber zu einem
haus wo er nun über den weg auf das haus
zu läuft jetzt sitzt er auf der flasche
und leute ich bin wirklich gespannt was
aus der flasche rauskommt wir sehen
schon es kommt scheiße raus
beziehungsweise andere köpfe nun schaut
er sich die flasche wieder an bewundert
sein meisterwerk nimmt einen flaschenzug
durch die flasche freut sich läuft
zurück den weg entlang und wir sehen
schon das ist das jetzt wahrscheinlich
wieder war oder
märz gedacht das war es dieses video
besteht aus einem piraten
das ist hier auf perez of the caribbean
der pirat
er fährt mit seinem schiff auf eine
einsame insel zu r feiert seinen
kollegen wer kennt nicht gegen das was
ich auf der insel befindet und auch
daraus kommen leute die nackt ranzen
leute ich mein berg endlich hat dieses
video heißt dinner und ist tatsächlich
ein 3d video beziehungen 360 grad wie du
das heißt wir können uns die ganze zeit
hier umdrehen sehen beispielsweise unter
uns befindet sich ein schildchen
bediener wir sehen hier ein schweinchen
diese frau feiert sich mega ab die
andere frau da ringsherum bringt essen
vorbei hier sitzen hund
ob diese person hat mir vorhin schon
gesehen bei dem ballett video ihnen hat
mir vorhin gesehen bei dem scheißen
video er jongliert irgendwelche eier
hier haben wir jemanden der feiert mit
ja mit einem hühnchen auf jeden fall er
freut sich dass gleich was essen kann
hier ist die person die sein essen durch
die luft schweben lässt und sie feiert
cool
und als letztes video gucken uns jetzt
das video rock'n roll an also wir sehen
eine person an einem schlagzeug eine
andere person die ich hier singt und das
ganze stellt natürlich eine band das
sieht man schon eher feiert sich mega ab
sieht aus wie albert einstein nun
bekommt eine andere dunkelhäutige person
aus dem himmel herab und fey alle sind
nackt
alle leute in diesem verpackten video
sind nackt ein nächster gitarrist der
seine zunge rausstreckt der sänger
streng erzogen raus hier haben wir
wieder die gitarristen die ganze masse
freut sich eher sinkt wieder freut sich
auch die ganze masse tobt alle feiern
sich jetzt geht es hier mega ab meine
damen und herren gehörte schon alle
gehen aber alle werden auf einmal vetter
es geht wirklich die luzie ab er
explodiert der sänger geht und das war's
best video auf
das war es jetzt auch schon wieder meine
damen und herren gestern hat mir sehr
viele gesagt dass ich das mal wieder
hochladen sollte man wieder darauf
reagieren soll also wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass ein like das schaffen
wir 1000
wenn wir das geschafft haben dann liegt
ihr nicht mehr
hier findet da oben rein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf klickt
könnte meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
dadurch verpasste keine videos mehr da
oben findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet wo am ersten juni eine neue
sommerkollektion launischen wird und
hier unten findet ihr ein weiteres video
verlinkt
also klickt es an